the spotlight was on the future of
southern nevada at las vegas perspective
today from talks of a recession to water
concerns joe moller shows us what local
leaders at the event say can help the
future of our area
with a lot up in the air when it comes
to the economy many are wondering what
could happen next there has to be though
a profound sense of urgency at the 2022
las vegas perspective event hosted by
las vegas global economic alliance major
topics were put in the spotlight land
talent and water those of you who study
economy you know the recession is coming
what's going to be our story at that
point dr darian pollard is the president
of nevada state college she expressed
the need for workforce development
education by far
is the most critical driving force in
securing business headquarters with the
ongoing drought water policy expert
cindy wallace lage discussed how
southern nevada can survive we are a
drying climate it is a shift
we have seen things we have created a
new normal she says we need to find
water supply alternatives so the reality
is we have to make change some of those
changes are going to be disruptive
economic expert brian gordon from
applied analysis touched on inflation
and the fears of recession i do not
expect us to see a repeat of where we
were thinking about the great recession
he says southern nevada faces challenges
to help the economy such as land
availability these are all the federal
lands within the urban las vegas valley
we can't build there he says we can grow
by building up and building smarter he
says working in our favor right now is
the popularity of las vegas and the
diversifying of the entertainment
industry we're bringing things like
formula one to las vegas in november of
2023. i'm telling you right now this is
a big deal joe muller live local now